what do you think is the future of
python in the next 10 20 50 years 100
years you look forward you ever think
about you ever imagine a future
of human civilization or living inside
the metaverse
on Mars
humanoid robots everywhere what part
does python play in that
it'll eventually become sort of a legacy
language uh that plays an important role
but that that most people have never
heard of and uh don't need to know about
just like
all kinds of
basic structures in in
biology like mitochondria
so it permeates all of life all of
digital life but people just build on
top of it and they only know the stuff
that's on top of it yeah
you guys can build layers of
abstractions I mean most programmers
nowadays
rarely need to do binary arithmetic
right
yeah or even think about it or even
learn about it or they could go quite
far without knowing I started
building little digital circuits out of
nand gates that I built myself with
transistors and resistors so I'd sort of
I feel very blessed that
with with that start when I was a
teenager
I I learned some of the basic at least
Concepts
that that go into building a computer
and I sort of every part
I have some understanding what
what it's for and why it's there and how
it works
and I can forget about all that most of
the time but I sort of
I enjoy knowing oh if you go deeper you
at some point you get to uh nand Gates
and have others and shift registers and
when it comes to the point of how do you
how do you actually make a chip out of
silicon I have no idea that's just magic
to me
but you enjoy knowing that you can walk
a while towards the lower and lower
layers but you don't need to it's nice
the other day as a sort of
a mental exercise I was trying to figure
out if I could build a
a flip-flop circuit out of uh relays
it was just sort of
trying to remember oh how does it really
relay work yeah there's like this
electromagnetic
force that pulls a switch open or shut
uh and you can have have like it can
open one switch and another shut another
and
uh you can have multiple contacts that
go at once and how many relays do I
really need to sort of represent one bit
of information can really just feed on
itself there was I don't think I I got
to the final solution but it was fun
that I
I could still do a little bit of problem
solving and thinking at that level
and it's cool how we build on top of
each other so there's people that are
just you you stood on the shoulders of
giants and there's others will stand on
your shoulders and it's it's a giant
beautiful hire yeah I feel I sort of
cover covered this middle layer of the
technology stack where and sort of
Peters out glow the
the level of of nand gates
and at the at the top I sort of I lose
track when it gets to machine learning
and then eventually the machine learning
will build higher and higher layers that
will help us understand the lowest layer
of the physics and thereby the universe
figures out how
it itself Works maybe maybe not
yeah I did I mean it's it's possible I
mean if you think of human consciousness
if that's even the right concept
it's it's interesting that that sort of
we have this super parallel brain that
does all these
incredible parallel operations like
image recognition
I recognize your face does you huge
amount of processing that goes on in
parallel there's lots of nerves between
my eyes and my brain
and the brain does a whole bunch of
stuff all at once because it's actually
a really slow circuits but there are
many of them that all work together
on the other hand when I'm speaking
everything is completely sequential
I I have to sort of string words
together one at a time
and when I'm thinking about stuff I'm
when I'm when I'm understanding the
world
I'm also thinking of everything like one
step at a time
and so we we've we've sort of we've got
all this this incredible
parallel circuitry in our brains and
eventually we use that to simulate a
single threaded much much higher level
interpreter
uh it's exactly I mean that's the
illusion of it that's the illusion
of it for us there's a single sequential
set of thoughts and all of that came
from a single cell through the process
of embryogenesis so DNA is the code
DNA holds the entirety of the code the
information and how to use that
information to build up an organism the
entire like
the arms how is it built yeah the brain
it's so it's you don't buy a computer
you buy like uh you buy a seed a diagram
and then you plant the computer and it
builds itself in almost the same way and
then does the computation and then is uh
eventually dies
it gets stale but gives birth to Young
computers
more and more and gives them lessons but
they figure stuff out on their own and
over time it goes on that way and those
computers when they go to college try to
figure out how to program and they build
their own little computers they're
increasingly more intelligent
increasingly higher and higher levels of
abstractions isn't it interesting that
that you sort of you see the same thing
appearing at different levels though
because you have like
cells that that create new cells
and and eventually that builds a whole
organism but then the animal or the
plant or the human
has its own mechanism of replication
that that is is sort of connected in a
very complicated way to the mechanism of
replication of the cells and then if you
if you look inside the cell if you see
how DNA and proteins are are connected
then there is yet another completely
different mechanism whereby proteins are
mass produced
using enzymes and and and a little bit
of code from from DNA and of course
viruses break into it at that level
and while the mechanisms might be
different it seems like the nature of
the mechanism is the same and it carries
across natural languages and programming
languages
humans
uh maybe even human civilizations or
intelligent civilizations
and then all the way down to uh the
single cell organism it is it is
fascinating to see what abstraction
levels
are built on top of individual humans
yeah and how you have like whole
societies
that that sort of have a similar
self-preservation
I don't know what it is Instinct nature
abstraction
as the individuals have and the cells
have and they self-replicate and breed
in different ways it's hard for us
humans to introspect it because we were
very focused on our particular layer of
abstraction but from an alien
perspective looking on Earth they'll
they'll probably see the higher level
organism of human civilization
as part of this bigger organism of life
on Earth itself in fact that could be an
organism just alone just life life life
on Earth
uh this has been a wild both
philosophical and Technical conversation
Guido you're you're an amazing human
being you're you're gracious enough to
talk to me when I was first doing this
podcast in one of the earliest first
people I've talked to uh somebody I
admired for a long time it's just a huge
honor that you did it at that time and
you do it again you're awesome thank you
Lex